quem nunca precisou sair na última hora
antes do jantar para comprar um
ingrediente que estava faltando
eu já e uma vez no supermercado
eu aproveitei e comprei algumas coisas
que estavam precisando em casa
comprei outras que eu imaginei que fosse
vir a precisar
na verdade me enche o carrinho na
esperança de não ter que voltar logo
para o supermercado
cheguei em casa super satisfeita cheia
de sacolas e me dei conta que não
comprei aquilo que eu fui pro
supermercado comprar todos os dias 25
milhões de brasileiros entram em um dos
84 mil supermercados espalhados pelo
brasil
é muita gente fazendo compras
é muita gente fazendo compras sem
planejamento que a gente planeja tanta
coisa na vida a gente planeja carreira a
gente planeja a aposentadoria
a gente planeja férias a gente não
planeja aquilo que faz pelo menos três
vezes ao dia à refeição quando a gente
faz compras sem planejamento
a gente leva para casa mais do que
precisa e esse excesso de alimento que a
gente leva só tem dois destinos
possíveis a nossa boca a boca do lixo da
cozinha o que acontece quando a gente
consome calorias demais
hoje no mundo nós temos 500 milhões de
obesos
o brasil tá com mais de 50% da população
acima do peso e todos os dias milhares
de pessoas morrem por erros de
alimentação e doenças relacionadas à
obesidade
uma pesquisa mostra que numa família de
classe média de um país industrializado
de cada cinco
bola de supermercado que entrou em casa
pelo menos uma vai parar no lixo a gente
acaba jogando fora 20% de todas as
carnes 20% de todos os laticínios 35%
dos peixes e frutos do mar são
desperdiçados e o pior 45% de todas as
frutas legumes verduras e leguminosas
na verdade um terço de tudo que é
produzido no mundo é perdido ou
desperdiçado isso enquanto uma em cada
nove pessoas sofrem de desnutrição
crônica
são 800 milhões de pessoas que não sabem
quando vão ter a próxima refeição sofrem
de insegurança alimentar
eu sei que ninguém gosta de jogar
alimento no lixo mas o que eu não sabia
é que o alimento que a gente
desperdiçara ele tem um impacto na nossa
economia
no nosso clima na nossa água e na
biodiversidade do planeta na economia
mais de 1 trilhão de dólares que são
desperdiçados junto com o alimento e
poderiam ser melhor aproveitados e sim
preço de produção não de consumo no
clima porque o alimento que a gente joga
fora normalmente vai para um aterro
sanitário onde ele passa a produzir
gases de efeito estufa
se o desperdício de alimento fosse um
país ele seria o terceiro maior emissor
de gás carbônico do mundo só perdendo
para a china e estados unidos
o alimento que a gente joga fora ele
também contém água agricultura ela
consome 70% da água potável utilizada
pelo homem só 11% vem para os municípios
19 por cento vai para a indústria no
alimento que nós desperdiçamos quer
dizer 28 por cento das terras
cultiváveis do mundo produzem um
alimento que não vai chegar no prato de
ninguém
a gente perde 205
tá quilômetros cúbicos de água o
equivalente ao fluxo anual do rio volga
é muita água é 3,6 vezes mais o que os
estados unidos inteiro gasta por ano
e aí a gente chega na questão da terra o
desmatamento pra agricultura pecuária já
é hoje a maior ameaça que nós temos a
biodiversidade e se esse gráfico mostra
o que que é preferível a gente fazer
para reduzir o desperdício nós
consumidores finais porque o desperdício
acontece desde o começo da cadeia de
produção e consumo e lá ele chama-se
perda de alimento e não desperdício ele
não pode ser evitado porque ele está
relacionado a questões financeiras
e isso acontece em países em
desenvolvimento mas nos países
industrializados o desperdício ele
acontece lá no final da cadeia e nós
consumidores finais nós temos um papel
muito grande neste desperdício e o que é
preferível é preferível reduzir e o -
preferível é que esse alimento vai parar
num aterro
qualquer solução para isso então é fazer
o planejamento
quando a gente faz uma lista de compras
baseada no planejamento de refeições a
gente tem a possibilidade de comprar só
o necessário para contemplá a nossa o
nosso planejamento dessa maneira não vai
sobrar nada mas também não vai faltar
nada
mas quem é que tem tempo pra isso a
gente não tem tempo e parece que os
recursos também tão sobre pressionados
por isso eu comecei a desenvolver uma
plataforma digital e um aplicativo para
que o consumidor final possa fazer isso
sem perder tempo da maneira de uma
maneira fácil de uma maneira tranquila
que vá ajudar a saber todo dia o que a
gente vai comer não ter que sair
correndo para comprar alguma coisa é
planejar refeições de acordo com
o perfil de consumo da família
a tecnologia eu acredito que seja a
melhor maneira de a gente responder a um
problema que cresce exponencialmente não
dá pra ter uma resposta analógica para
um problema que é tão grande sendo que a
gente não tem tempo hábil pra poder no
nosso dia a dia para poder resolver isso
e é tão importante também a gente passar
a planejar refeições e reduzir o
desperdício da nossa casa porque essa é
a única maneira que a gente tem de fazer
aquela uma sacolinha das cinco que a
gente leva pra casa deixar de existir
porque quando a gente consegue reduzir o
desperdício de alimento em casa a gente
consegue mandar uma mensagem para os
varejistas e para os produtores de
alimento diminuírem a produção hoje nós
produzimos no mundo 4 mil e 600 calorias
por habitante diariamente
só que a gente não precisa de quatro mil
e 600 calorias para viver
a gente precisa de menos da metade disso
tem alguma coisa muito errada
estamos produzindo demais essa produção
não chega em quem precisa e ela acaba
ocasionando aqueles dois problemas a
obesidade e desperdício que impacta
negativamente no meio ambiente a uns 500
anos copérnico tirou a terra do centro
do universo mas às vezes dá a impressão
de que o homem ainda não saiu de lá
o gel centrismo foi derrubado mas o ego
centrismo continua firme
nós precisamos começar a cuidar do nosso
planeta e tem uma relação diferente com
ele e talvez a gente possa fazer isso
através da cozinha porque talvez essa
seja a maior rede social ligado